tanth ah
ah ah ah
Well, it's
almost time to run out of balls
Actually, I'm like that, but if I
don't reach 9000
, tan
[music]
Chimi
I've never seen a face like a
so-called bounty hunter.
I thought I knew about it
, but maybe the
scene
[music] is
n't impregnated Hey, it's
such a dangerous job Parents are also worried about
it, aren't
they?  I'm picking up girls right now, but I've been hit with a
bounty, so I haven't had a chance to get close to a girl
.
I'm a bokeh
Sharl's push hat man
[music]
nib Volume 1
me
[music]
love me I
've eaten into wealth I've
discarded everything
Conceited small now ride me
[music]
bananaman
nome da brother
me
lead up to here
[music]
me
ranni
ah ah
ano
ang
me
[music]
I can eat soldering to a pillar
Yes
Chop Chateau-chan,
I told you
not to use the sensitivity code, right
?  Hey,
wait a minute, Chateau-
chan.
You're the daughter of your father's benefactor, aren't you?
But then please go ahead.
Burke may continue to be quite dangerous
. You're
entrusting too much milk to the underworld for this child
.
Even the
politicians and the police, who wield a great
deal of power, have tolerated this.  It's a
shame to live in a different house.
Chateau-chan, I
'm just asking about your request today,
so please don't buy it. The
answer is
yes
. This is the 18th floor.
About a
year ago, I had to act as an interpreter for three dogs who were a powerhouse in Asian distribution Mishima As I wrote, I believe it was dismantled five years ago yeah, it
was caused by the assassination of executives who set it up
10 people including the top overnight  18 people
have been killed.
At that time, there was quite a stir. He was a
very dangerous person.
I
'm over 20 in real life, but my page amount is the highest
.
Please consider the exclusive contract.
It
seems
like they're going to bribe companies
like us to kill
Nha.
Inside,
don't worry,
I'm working on something else right now Sasha-chan, we're bounty hunters, and we're far from outspoken temperament, aren't we?
Even if you don't choose
[music]
because you don't
have it, you'll get a receipt
ah ah ah
[music]
march I'm tired.
Oh
, the fresh juice from the store is
delicious.
Oh
, I'm glad it's orange
.
Nisa  This guy
doesn't seem like a big deal, but
[music]
What's the purpose?
ere
[music]
I'm out of my mind It's just an excuse to get
you to pay attention to me, but there
aren't any
patrons like me.  Hey
, you can't take it easy if it's sudden.
San
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah Isa tan ah um ah ah
time group
still has time
[music]
Wheeee Minami ah
that's why you're a rogue image that you've hung outside It's a
work river
No way expense  So you didn't buy it
3 f
Even so, you're trying to divert people's conversations
.
Well,
after finishing work, the living room on the floor
is nice, right?  '
Cause no,
I'm just making excuses for Shikoku
.  Music]
Hey, I'm not interested in this kind of thing, so I don't wear it at all Hey, it's something I don't really
need,
and I'd like to give it to you as a present
I don't want to say it, why do you have a recommendation
?  Music]
Hey
, there's something I like Let's watch it together
Wait a minute
r If it's early 9, you can't
count it as a date unless you walk side by side
Hey, it's a day like this and it can't be helped, but you should be a little more shy walking around this kind of town Are you
okay?  It's
a room with a beautiful
night view.
Sounds like he made a lot of money from a very small business
Hey, that
guy
used his mistress to run a beauty salon these days People who get
caught are stupid too But
hey, a
corpse is fine
Think of it as a Christmas present
[music]
You cancer
me  I don't know how you want to use it
.
f
Hey, let's go back to the deal as you wish
[music]
Now let's
eat
[music]
It's about time
I didn't listen to the children,
hymns of the choir tt I also hated
illuminations  Hey
Chateau, it would have been nice if we were together, but it's
a pity.
It's fine
here.It's terrible at the hotel I
was at earlier.You said it was a job you did, so I
canceled my stay, but the
receptionist was looking at me with a lot of pity
.
Wait, let me check one thing
[music]
After all,
I don't care about the smell
.
This love's terminal station is because
your tears are coming out
goo-n On
the way we
're going Shinonaga Fraud must be happening
Can you see Joe's name? [Music] 4 minutes Pyon r It's time for something to change here It
's a relatively good start Aligning the fragments of memories
and love and
swaying in a Benz
I don't want to lose my foot, so I can't go
ni
ani
le's
[music]
ah ah
ni
[music]
me
without knowing
period
[music]
ni ah ah ah
Target next time